[Music]
you made it weird with Pete Holmes
what's happening weirdos this is an
incredible and very very special episode
very special like Family Matters one
that have like a special one but it is
this is James Finley who's an incredible
I'm gonna say it he's like a Mystic I
feel like Katie and I we drove uh
towards the beach in California here and
we went up into his house and we sat
with at first I was like this is like a
hobbit but then as we chatted I was like
no this is Gandalf this is a magic
beautiful eloquent gift of a person and
I'm so glad you guys are here a lot of
you probably don't know who James is and
that does not matter just imagine uh
that you're sitting with me and him by
uh by a crackling fire and just absorb
crackling fire but just absorb the
wisdom that's what I did this
conversation touched me changed me
everything he says and does is just
poetry including his new book which is
called the healing path which is
incredible he also has a podcast called
Turning to the mystics where he dissects
and breaks down a different Mystic from
different Traditions he's incredible he
teaches at the CAC at the center for
action and contemplation which is
Richard Richard Rohr as you know I love
Richard Rohr that's his organization and
James is a master teacher there so I'm
so glad to have been able to visit with
him and I'm so glad we recorded it and
I'm so glad you guys are here to listen
to it do check out the healing path it
is incredible uh and it is out it is
available right now I'm also on tour if
you're hearing this the day that this
comes out I'm gonna I'm about to tape my
special uh I believe it's on the 6th
June 6th that sounds right early June I
believe on the sex in Minneapolis I'm
also going to be in a bunch of other
places coming up Cleveland comes to mind
Denver comes to mind go to petehomes.com
I'm going to be touring for a while
while so if I'm coming to a town near
you it would mean a lot the shows have
been so great Madison and Milwaukee this
past weekend were incredible so hope to
see you out I'm so proud of this hour
it's so fun and the special taping for
tickets to the special taping uh which
is going to be incredible go to
petehomes.com for all of that we're also
brought To Us by our friends at
magicmind you guys hear me talk a lot
about magic mind it is definitely the
product that has changed my life the
most in the past years it is an Elixir
basically it's a magical Elixir that
helps you focus better on your work be
more creative and drink less coffee
their slogan is do more stress less
because it has adaptogens in there that
help you cope with stress has
neurotropics that help you focus and be
creative just a little bit of caffeine a
little bit of honey it's incredible
tastes amazing and there's a mix of 12
functional ingredients including matcha
and other things that help you fight off
stress and to dial in and focus in fact
in is the perfect way to put it it
doesn't get you wired in fact it's a
great substitute for coffee sometimes
instead of that second cup I'll just
have a magic mine or I take a magic mine
with my first cup and that's all I need
for the day 30 more done on average five
to seven hours thirty percent more
productivity imagine what you would do
with that fighting off procrastination
brain fog fatigue I'm actually sitting
at this computer behind me I'm doing
some writing today absolutely take a
magic mind before I do that getting you
easy easy into that flow State and they
have a money back guarantee any first
purchase will be refunded no questions
asked if it doesn't meet your
expectations and we have a special deal
Go to magicmind.com weird and use
discount code at checkout weird for a
limited 20 off your first order that's
magicmind.co slash weird news discount
code weird support your mind support
your body support your creativity and
support this show love magic mind
obsessed all right everybody let's get
into this chat with James Finley so glad
you're here get into it I thought I mean
I set it off but now we're recording
I'll say what a pleasure it's so nice to
be here with you thank you and with
Katie in your beautiful home I thought
I'd start I felt it felt appropriate
I was looking for a bathroom
I wonder how much wisdom or truth we
could extrapolate from just the
experience of me driving to your place
and I had to pee uh and I was looking
for a bathroom and I parked first of all
finding parking very difficult
and then I went into a Starbucks and I
don't know if you know the Starbucks
closest you just doesn't have a bathroom
which I was right it does which is
inappropriate they're in the back
they're in the public BM business yeah
and they also think the reason why you
need a bathroom exactly and they don't
give up it's full circle but they're
only it's a half circle it's not right
it's not right and I went in and I was
shocked I literally thought that's one
of their main functions in society is
it's not just me but on House people and
stuff they know Starbucks has got them
covered but I couldn't go but I was
looking at the suffering meaning using
Richard's definition uh out of control
yeah I like that that definition and I
was noticing how much I was creating at
the anxiety that I was like what if I
never find one you know you have that
childish voice I'm gonna explode or be
humiliated or something or for me it's
like I I'm not special I'm not loved if
I if no one will let me in
and give me help I I feel that and then
eventually I did find a restaurant I
walked in I was just real honest I was
like they seemed closed I was like look
I'll buy something it's a real hat man
I'll buy something I just need a
bathroom and he was like he got and and
there was real love in it there really
was I felt it he he made a choice to go
please use the bathroom tell me tell me
what you take from that hairstyle here's
what I take from this story tiny story I
look on it as the physiology of
spirituality
and Thomas Merton says he says perhaps a
great deal of our difficulty in the
spiritual life could be cured by a
simple respect for the body like we're
incarnate beings you know and that
includes the mind yeah it includes yeah
we're incarnate bodily in the mind as
incarnated as in the brain the brain but
then also the mind is ontological and
spiritual it's not Material right and uh
so were this incarnate uh Alchemy yeah
of the physical and this and the
invisible people in the spirituals and
there was so God hiding and needing to
pee or or yeah yeah God's hiding until
you have these kind of sensitivities and
it's not hiding anymore right you know
go take a holy p and be grateful it was
a glorious peace yes it wasn't a peace
and you know what I was totally there
for it you know what I mean mindfulness
yes and it was the I often think of the
bow string of of the tension so we're
putting tension on the Arrow was me not
being able to find parking me not
finding a bathroom and and but it
informed about my wife Val and I talk
all about how we want to push the
pleasure buttons right we want to feel
good we even spiritually I want to feel
Transcendent I want to feel peaceful I
want to feel Bliss or Joy but everything
no matter how many times I've learned
this lesson is informed by the the
tension that came before it is that
another inside it had too is that um
that God is God is uh being infinitely
poured out and given away holding
complete in and as the primordial
rhythms of our days so standing up and
sitting down waking up and going to
being alone and being with others God's
the Infinity of those rhythms then I say
and God's waiting for us to discover her
there because I God forever comes to
visit but we're rarely at home because
we're probably out buying a spiritual
book somewhere
oh no don't say that a lot of monastic
life is about this it's like an
endlessly ordinary life you know it's
just endless ordinariness I said you
live in Silence You chant the Psalms you
worked in the fields yes and you have
one bowl
you had a no you had a when I was there
you had a soup bowl it was vegetarian
meal yeah you had a soup bowl with
yesterday's vegetables in it with water
mixed for the soup and then you had a
plate on top of that with two vegetables
and bread and water you gotta do bread
because Jesus is
okay at least they give you coffee that
was a meal but I like the this when I
have you seen the movie into great
silence it's a great movie no one knows
this movie I love that movie whoever
wrote that nose that's really whoever
that's the life I lived at the monastery
yes they had the intuition yes yeah and
so for people that don't know they LED
this French documentary crew into a
monastery carthusian Monastery of hermit
carthusian isn't it fun that we
sometimes do live in a Tolkien book like
there are people called the girls that
live in a castle and a lot of talking
really I was thinking about it on uh the
creative imagination yeah and uh that
came out of talking's imagination as as
a religious sensitivity to the nature of
reality
yes on the Mythic uh rhythms and layers
of reality yes it was brilliant okay I'm
going to write down token so we don't
forget that because I I completely agree
with you going back to those rhythms
have you I I'm assuming you have
meaning I don't want to feel silly for
asking you an obvious question but has
there ever come over you that even in
our physiology there's give and take
there's inhale exhale you know those
moments where it seems so obvious at
other times the mystery seems so distant
and then other times you're just like
it's right it's right here it's it's in
my breath it's in eating and excreting
and sleeping and waking uh yeah here's
one way I put it
is um
uh
when we when we inhale
uh the body doesn't stop to see whether
or not it's gonna accept the inhalation
like we gotta question you first right
because the body is the acceptance of
the next inhalation
the body is the extent which is
receiving the gift of life because if
you don't inhale the rest of the day
won't go well you know what I mean it's
like we're running rough shot
over the depth of what we're looking for
and it's present in the breath and
likewise when we exhale we exhale
ourself so in the re and also notice
that although we don't know how many
times we've inhaled and exhaled from the
day we were born no matter how many
times you have inhaled it's this equal
to how many times you've exhale plus or
minus one right so there's a rhythm
built right in that's a big plus or
minus one right there huge one it's a
huge yeah yeah one more time she died
right here in the living room hospice
yeah and I watched her sitting right
next to her holding her hand and uh and
uh she exhaled and didn't inhale and I
thought that's what death is death is
it's not an event it's a cessation it's
the end you know and I could tell right
away she wasn't there anymore unless she
was right there and then she wasn't and
then she wasn't there greater than the
sense of human heat or body warm exactly
they were not read we're not we're we're
incarnate we're incarnate in and as our
body but we're not reducible to the body
right yeah I is it the I think it's
Chinese then it says it's like breaking
a Vaz and the air that was in the Vaz is
released no it's an image that stuck
with me yeah about death but isn't it
funny and correct me if I'm wrong but I
feel like the ego or our thinking Minds
our monkey Minds would actually prefer a
system where the body checks the breath
and goes like is this Worthy is this
worthy of us oh my gosh what I think it
is too is there's a
a level at which we experience and need
a sense of control over the situation
and that's real you know there's the
schedule and am I keeping up and what do
I have to do but the need to control
overstates its case
that's a big overstation game because
we're we're not like I said we didn't
bring ourselves into existence we can't
keep ourselves in existence as evidenced
by death yes and so we don't belong to
ourselves yeah so can I learn to trust
so when I take a breath like from once
as it arrives
and so I'm trying to learn it's like
with love too like Intimacy in deep
surrender there's a kind of a controller
order to a loving relationship but the
essence of a surrendering
people surrendering themselves over to
the kind of ecstasy of Love or The
rhythms of Love yeah that transcends
what they can control yes because if
they can control it it wouldn't be love
right you know well the William Blake
poem uh uh a man in a room sit together
speaking or not speaking loving I'm
paraphrasing it poorly but loving a
third thing that neither of them can see
again I I'm hoping you deserve aware of
that that's exactly right right yeah
I should know him better we read it at
my wedding damn it yeah
but people can look it up as a beautiful
poem it is oh here's here's pictures of
Maureen and I when we met and she died
yeah and here's our wedding vows here
I'll read it to you please
um
we were both spiritual directors and
psychotherapists together those are our
wedding vows
I James Finley take you Maureen Fox to
be my wife from this day forward to love
cherish and care for till death do us
part I vow to you my honesty and
vulnerability day by day walking our
walk into all our unknown tomorrows I
know that to grow I must continue dying
and it is you I choose to live and die
with Head to Head toe-to-toe soul to
soul this day and forever you are truly
my best friend lover and soul mate the
one through whom God calls me to be my
true self this day I vow to accept this
call
wow she wrote this beautiful I knew you
got to do it you plagiarized her
that is gorgeous what a gift gave us for
sharing that that's that that's that
energy isn't it as you were reading that
I've been married twice the first time
was as a fundamentalist the second time
was as a as an aspiring Mystic hopefully
getting more in touch with that William
Blake but the first time it was so much
more to do with whether or not we had
had sex as you were talking the ABS you
said lover the absurdity of going like
how do you two slept together you know
before your wedding back to what it got
turned into me too when I left the
monastery I got married right away and
ended in divorce oh really yeah and um
you have two daughters so that marriage
which is a real Grace I'm very close to
both of them and um
just all unraveled fell apart when I got
my doctorate for my I got a scholarship
for my doctorate in Psychology and we
moved out here part of it was the stress
of the doctorate but it was PR it was
troubled we were both troubled and
kind of half crazy really yeah and fell
apart and then that's when I met Maureen
so did isn't that how it goes
just reminds me of my own story but the
monastic life were I feel like you maybe
had been incubated a little bit or is
that unfair
to be catapulted into maybe the most
secular thing you know like a marriage
yeah I would say in a way yes because
see because this is just before the
Vatican Council so some of it's changed
but then we slept in a straw mattress on
boards in a common dormitory just
partitions in the monastery yeah got up
at 2 30 in the morning a chanted the
Psalms seven times the canonical why
don't we go into bed if we're getting up
at seven o'clock okay that's not
horrible I guess it cloistered so there
was no Act of ministry you didn't help
me nothing just it was the hidden life
and no one came in either so it was a
cloistered hidden life no television no
radio no newspapers well nothing I was
it was like Willy Wonka's chocolate
factory no one goes in and no one comes
out right you know except instead of
chocolate you have Temperance yeah what
it is really is God
I would sit with Thomas Merton in
spiritual Direction
um
that I thought that all of our sessions
together there were like three questions
there one was he would ask how's it
going
um that's what's it like being you
living here you came here to live does
this feel like where you belong
secondly you would ask how is it going
and you're surrendered to the mystery
that accessed your heart and brought you
to this place that it might transform
you into itself
I'm gonna need you to say it again how's
it going in your surrender to the
mystery God yes how's it going your
surrender to the mystery that accessed
your heart and brought you to this place
that it might transform you into itself
divinization through love
because God is love see what would it
mean there'd be nothing left of you but
love yes and uh that's a great question
yes doesn't it break your heart a little
bit that we just say like have you seen
look I'm not putting it down but have
you seen the new blah blah or have you
have you eaten this or whatever not that
we can't have God and all that too but
that question has made me kind of well
up a little bit Yeah I do think and then
he said the third question was
how's it going
and you you being faithful to
experiencing the depth of the second
question
percolating up to the messy unresolved
details of the first question
because you're still just trying to find
your way through another day you know
you're still just you after the Ecstasy
the laundry yeah what is it when the
laundry is infinite
because it's God being poured out and
given away as the laundry and it's
nothingness without God yeah so what
would it mean to be to to be sensitized
to that you know like the everything's
deserving of respect or even reverence
in his ordinariness and so this life
then becomes a life of kind of Incarnate
Infinity intimately realized so when I
left the monastery it was like culture
shock coming out here but then I
realized I still wanted to live that way
so how did everyone live this way in the
world
it's the hottest married life or single
life or divorced life or parenting or a
long-term illness or teaching children
in a classroom how does it have built
right into it the capacity to find one's
way to this death dimension of it and
then live bite and share it with others
do we know yes I mean we that's the path
I was hoping you would say yes yes how
did it how did that unfold for you I
asked father father Greg Boyle I was
like where do we find our Rejuvenation
and goes in every damn breath is what he
said and I was like what a great
response I think um
um
well first of all I will put it this way
is that um
we're living at we're living our day by
day life
doing our sincere best to be um a
present engaged vulnerable honest
tender-hearted person
knowing that we stumbled and fall over
and over again
and know that every time we fall our
acceptance of our frailties the portal
through which the mercy of God sustains
us like an infinitely love broken person
and I'm living it in a situation like a
minute this is this is our situation I'm
always in a situation
and then there are certain moments when
I'm graced with a touch of the Divinity
of life so Merton talks about the new
seeds of contemplation at the end he
says say you're out walking the midst of
Nature and you turn to see a flock of
birds descending and as if out of the
corner of your eye you catch something
in their descent that's primordial vast
and true and you pause and sit there
like there's something sacred about it
something sacred about you being able to
see that he said when we know love in
our own Hearts like intimate communion
with someone uh reading a small child a
good night's story
lying awake in the middle of the night
listening to your breathing the smell of
a flower there are certain moments where
we're grazed
but they were like we're suffering we
get the feeling that I think too that
we're carried Along by the momentum of
the day's demands
sensing that we're skimming over the
surface of the depths of our own life
like we're suffering from Death
deprivation
and the tragedy is that God's
unexplainable Oneness with us is hidden
in the depths over which we're skimming
yeah but in these fleeting moments
there's like a descent if we drop down
into that depth like we taste it and
just for a moment we pause in it
sometimes it's very intense but usually
it's very delicate
so the next step is then I think is uh
we experience the desire to abide in the
depths of leadingly glimpsed like
homecoming I don't like living on the
outer circumference of the inner depths
of my own life which I know is there
because from time to time I taste it um
and so then the path is this this three
like tripod the path
is a we can't make these moments happen
but we can assume the inner stance that
offers the least resistance to be
overtaken by what we cannot attain so
lovers cannot make their moments of
oceanic Oneness happen but together they
can assume the stance it offers the
least resistance to being overtaken one
more time with Oneness in love and Poets
can't make the poet poem happen but they
can assume the stance that offers at
least those committed to Healing can't
make healing happen
and so this is meditation practice so
it's like a daily Rendezvous it's a
daily Rendezvous Ed Martin says with God
a little sincerity goes a long long way
like Here I Am Lord and he said in the
spiritual life to understand is to
realize that you're infinitely
understood
and that you belong to God and so you
sit and usually how it begins then is
this idea of lectio Divina discursive
meditation and prayer lectio as you take
a text and the christianers will be the
Gospels it could be any poet or Saint or
whatever and you would read it so Jesus
says fear not I'm with you always
uh to the power of the spirit who dwells
in our hearts we believe that the
deathless presence of Jesus is
personally telling us not to be afraid
he's with us always like this and so the
lectio is attentive listening to words
that are beautiful and you know they're
beautiful even before you think about it
the fact that he's with us always come
what BAE up till death and beyond it's
beautiful and then God then the next
step of the latter is God says now that
I spoke to you you talk to me so
meditation is a dialogue between herself
and God about fear and about presence
about and the third rung of the latter
is prayer which is desire like help me
with this and what can happen and then
at the end of each sitting like a
rendezvous each day
and you ask for the grace to not to
break the threat of that sensitivity as
you go through the day and if you do
that daily like Fidelity to the
Rendezvous little by little it can
become habituated to your day and can
then blossom into contemplation which is
wordless Union like a Oneness beyond
words and you can do that uh you know I
mean you can you said someone once said
to to live this way in today's world is
like someone trying to make a u-turn at
rush hour on the freeway it goes against
the stream the world does not encourage
us to do this yeah by saying unless I
decide I'm going to live this way you
know with utter sincerity and you just
quietly do it and uh until it becomes
habituated through your whole day and
people can do that it's beautiful I mean
there's a page and be here now where
they talk about where you can find your
faith from and one of the places the
holy tax and then one of them is is the
idea that other people have done it and
I'm one of those people that I take
great comfort and just hearing you say
yeah I don't have to go all the way back
to Christ or whoever I can go ugh and
I've experienced that in my own life
these little little steps I don't want
to say forward but Little Steps well I
would say this too I I had no idea who
you were my daughters are great fancy I
don't know why my grandchildren do they
would have a while Pete's coming here
like Rondo Applause so I started
watching your interviews Conan oh no
different things very funny
but I think this too and I talked to
Richard Rohr about you wanting to talk
to me and he has such a respect for you
and uh so the sincerity of you wanting
to have interviews like this is that
somehow your comedy embodies a way of
sharing something about the likeness of
Life do I mean it's like a little touch
it's a ping it is it like it matters
like where would life be without that
yeah and uh I heard you talk about that
you look back on in your life when a
time like a conversation like this would
have been absurd you know and the
Gratitude you and I can both have that
we found we found this because when you
say we skim across the surface of Our
Lives I'd like throw I feel like that's
the mass of men that's that's most
people it is and that's a heartbreaker
it is a heartbreaker somehow I put it to
people too as I say
um like how has it come to pass
that you've come to be the person who's
even capable of being concerned about
such things at the level which and is it
not true that maybe a year ago or five
years ago wasn't true so you're on a
path not of your own making otherwise
this would make no sense right you're
making no sense and so how then can I be
grateful for this path and keep leaning
into it so it can keep getting deeper
and deeper yes yeah I have that with our
the listeners of this podcast believe it
or not because I go who are you I say
this to the people listening now who are
you that will not only look past but
enjoy a comedian who talks about BMS at
a Starbucks or or the graphicness of sex
or or the cruelty of the world that's
right swearing uh I I'm I'm in for all
of it I love all I think it's all funny
I think it's all worth talking about but
so few people are interested in talking
about Thomas Merton contemplation uh
coming to God by doing it wrong not by
doing it right Richard Rohr James Finley
uh father Greg Boyle and also will enjoy
a good diarrhea joke or whatever it may
be like you lose so whoever is here I go
who are you and I celebrate yeah Martin
a person was very funny yes and uh had a
sense of humor for example when I was at
the monastery it was a gothic church and
they they redid it they stripped it out
and so it's just the bear bricks and so
on when they first built it but then it
was a kind of a redone and the windows
were done in Europe somewhere these very
tall Gothic windows
and uh
uh Saint Berner clairvaux in the 11th
century founder of the cistercians which
is the order that Merton belonged to
this Clay Street monastery
he talked about contemplation as
drinking Mary's milk and so they made a
window of that
So This Tall window marries up in heaven
with angels around her and she's holding
the baby Jesus and baby Jesus is leaning
back and she's squeezing her breasts and
burners down on the ground at the bottom
of the window kneeling down with his
arms like this and his mouth open and
the strings going in his mouth and
Martin says you know secretly over all
these years I've always called that
window Mary scores a bullseye
he was so funny that way he was so
clever you know what I mean yes there's
something that that image is almost
it's so right it's uncomfortable exactly
yeah and it has to do with this
incarnate Divinity of the details of
ordinariness yes and and not the
grossness
and not even the grotescence but it's
the obviousness I suppose the milk and
the sperm and egg and the blood and the
you know like that I like that image
because it's not
it's not ignoring what's happening it's
not covering it in robes and yeah and
pretending that it's all clouds and
Michelangelo it's sometimes something
much more yeah that's why that's why I
always think too that um what I told
people in these silent Retreats that
uh when we do sitting practice and all
of it we think we're waiting for some
big thing to happen yeah sometimes big
things do happen
Martin once they were all holding off
for it someday we'll get zapped by God
and they'll have to prop us up in a
corner and fan us you know like we're
kind of but I think they're getting the
vapors yeah but I think sometimes things
like that do happen actually yeah but
what I think it is is opposite is
calibrating the heart to a fine enough
scale that you can find in a single
breath yeah that you know the the the
the the
generosity of the infinite is infinite
and we are the generosity of God we're
the song God sings and he can get so
quiet we're so delicate that you can
there's a there's a sense of that you're
touched by the truth of that right which
is contemplation yes and then you can
habituate that sensitivity through the
day yes little by little it's an
underlying thing you just sense is
always the Buddhists say you know don't
grow a second head I don't think here's
your ordinary head then up here is your
enlightened head so it's just the
ordinariness of wiping down the kitchen
counters or looking out the window and
there's a felt scent it's like this
matters you know in a way that's beyond
what I can explain I got the images you
were speaking it's like we're playing as
we grow older we start playing on these
pianos you know they make pianos for
children that are like just a few Keys
it's just like one octave yeah and we
play on that and we feel like I'm a big
piano thing but really we can as you
said recalibrate our sensitivity right
open the the iris on the camera a little
bit more and let it in that's right last
night I was watching uh Eckhart Tolle
video I think you know for all the
things the internet gives us that might
be distracting or strange or whatever
sometimes you just stumble on an Eckhart
toll and he starts talking about
forgetting not knowing what you are
meaning we're always trying to know what
we are we want to know our true self and
he's actually talking about knowing your
true self by not knowing yourself going
Beyond concept he's like when you sink
into something like doing the dishes so
completely that you stop thinking and
you stop thinking of yourself as a
concept or God is a concept or the
moment is a concept and there's this
quiet heavy as I've heard you say Abyss
that just kind of it doesn't know it
doesn't have subject object it's just
made of knowing and it's accessible
that's really true it's accessible while
you're doing the dishes is what you're
saying not just
again like your your marriage going did
you have sex before you got married it's
like do you go to church it's like
can you do the dishes right it's true
it's really true let's define I'd love
to hear what were some of those things
people are going to wonder let's give
the people you know the Romano maharshi
quote I give people what they want so
they want what I give they'll tell the
miracle stories what is the story of
something strange that happened maybe to
you maybe you're telling me that
sometimes in deep meditation strange
things happen
when I wrote my Memoir I told the story
of my own experiences and then sitting
with I worked with trauma for 30 years
so I just sat with people listened to a
lot of stories so I'll share one story
Every Woman share with me without sure
something that I experienced
um I've seen this woman in therapy and
when she was a little girl her parents
never physically or emotion or sexually
abused her but they would violently
fight with each other in front of her
just terrify her but they were so angry
at each other they couldn't see what
they were doing to her but she felt
invisible
and she told me and therefore she still
feels invisible inside that's why she
was in therapy
and uh she told me that One Summer Night
they were screaming at each other and
she opened the back screen door the
patio went into the backyard in the dark
and there was a tree in her backyard and
she climbed up in the low branches of
the tree and she said she closed one eye
and lined up a twig with a star
and said to God if you know I'm here
make the star move to the other side of
that twig like it'll just be between us
right I've done this and she says uh God
didn't move the star
and then she said but there's something
about the remembrance of myself sitting
alone in the dark in the low branches of
a tree Waiting for God to move his star
that consoles me
and I say to I said to her you know it's
true that God didn't move the star
but in remembering that here with me you
were moved and sharing it I could see it
and because you shared it I was moved
and this is how God works in our life
all right I said so let's make a deal in
the therapy anytime we feel stuck well
imagine we're sitting together in the
low branches of that tree Waiting for
God to move a star because I think that
a lot of therapies like this these
shifts happen
intimately you know I mean it kind of we
build up to something and then there's
this kind of dropping it down yes and a
lot of the healing is uh the that's the
healing of the depth Dimension this
unexpected descent into a grounded
intimate place you can tell us you can't
explain it but you know it's true uh
Thomas Merton once said uh the most
important things in our life
are things we can't explain there are
certain things in life we simply have to
accept as true or we go crazy inside and
they're the very things we can't explain
to anybody including ourselves
and Dan wall said teaching class of
metaphysics at the monastery he used to
say I know what I know it I know that I
know it but the trouble is is I who know
that I know it and when I try to tell
you what it is that I know that I know I
don't know what to say
because if everything you knew is what
you could say would just be more of this
yeah words were but there's something
there's something that's utterly
transcending the sum total of all this
the swelling up and is the reality of
all this and I can taste it in a moment
of awe or Mercy or art or silence or
whatever and I can learn to and the
words are sort of twice removed it's
funny we want I'd love to hear you speak
on this
we want the story of the star that moved
the movie would be about the story
but I think what I'm hearing you speak
of is interior realities which are so
real
spiritual depth psychological depths
emotional depths and that's most of our
experience like we can see all this but
really it's all in here and that story
you know metaphorically I'm experiencing
a star move we want it to happen out
here right does that make sense but
things that transform
internally need to be celebrated as
Miracles as such too
yes yes I I said here's how I see it
I think sometimes God does move the star
for example I went to the monastery
radicalize me there at God
and um years later I've met Maureen
lived here with her for 30 years so she
died God moved the star
and I was in Psychotherapy it got a
doctorate uh when I got left left the
monastery I wrote Martin's Palace of
nowhere I was a high school religion
teacher
and uh a Martin's idea of the true
self-ultimate identity Beyond ego
and when that book came out
um I got invited to give silent Retreats
around the United States and Canada and
one of the first Retreats I ever gave
was a clinical psychologist who had read
the book
and he said if you'd be willing to
commit yourself to exploring the
contribution the contemplative
spirituality and the mystics make the
mental health I'll give you a PhD in
Psychology for free with family support
not alone I was living in Cleveland Ohio
and I moved with my wife at the time and
two small children came to Fuller
Theological Seminary in Pasadena and
spent five years in full-time doctoral
work and became a psychotherapist so God
does move the star yeah but there's two
things about it though
when I look at each of these things when
you actually get there what matters most
isn't the details that enticed you at
first
because whenever we want something and
if we finally get it isn't what we
thought it was but if we let it it's
even more than we thought it was and
it's messy challenges it's a call like
that so in that sense even when God does
move the star the the interior star the
miracle is an unexpected interior
this feels like I give people what they
want exactly and then also what happens
sometimes God doesn't move the star yeah
and the good God just doesn't
and so then you seek to find
that's why I say that this the the this
path is uh
oh here give me this I'll read this
message someone asked me to say this on
this I just came from this retreat in
Madison
I'm going to Madison oh I was just there
this weekend two weeks Madison Wisconsin
yeah the retreat directors International
they had their National
uh thing there and I give the quinoa it
was great
and I gave it another talk
uh with the mindfulness training program
people and uh it was in the building
designed by Frank Lloyd Wright well you
should go there it's really yeah it
talks are just like it's just gorgeous
oh I love seeing it here's your three
quotes
on what on uh when when the star doesn't
move yes please
finding our way along the healing path
does not consist of striving for some
far-off goal that we may or may not
attain
it is rather a way of discovering a
secret hidden deep within our hearts
finding our way along the healing path
does not consist of figuring out some
obscure teaching but rather consist of
learning to see God hidden and revealed
in all that we see
and finding our way along the healing
path does not consist of mastering some
method of meditation but rather consist
of learning not to do violence to the
fragility of our waiting
because somehow I think that if I'm
waiting for something to be delivered
from some pain or I mean whatever it is
uh and it's not forthcoming
if I just sit and wait something's given
to me in the waiting
this changing me like the star not
moving exactly so it doesn't move and
yet yes see what I've learned along the
way I don't know how to explain it I
learned something about what matters
most or about
you know I mean like the substance of
things yes but we're obsessed with the
materials
oh yeah I might even say distracted by
something else exactly
T.S Eliot says I was distracted by the I
was distracted from the distraction by a
distraction yes you know wait pull the
number wait you're telling me distracted
by you later well you're not even being
fully distracted no it's distracting you
no and I and also what I think it is too
is that like why why is that right and I
think it's because
um
we're uncomfortable
with being quietly vulnerable
in an intimate immediacy of our self
that we're not used to yes that's what I
was going to say what don't we want to
feel is that exactly right and the
trouble is because we avoid that which
is also the
people get married and avoid that with
each other yes you know they cook
Inspire do it they cook Inspire they
lady even though they're married looking
for it yeah and but if you if you go
like why do people go to art museums or
why do people I think we're all why do
people come here and walk along the
ocean out here we're all looking for it
and yet to find it to drop down in the
depths we have to drop down through and
accept layers of ourselves that have
pain ripping in it yeah
yeah and we've got to be willing to walk
with that pain and to understand it and
accept it maybe get help with it and
that pain avoidance which is the layers
we have to go through
to find the pure gold that's hidden
underneath it keeps a lot of people at
the edge of themselves I think we say
this on the show all the time most
people would do way more to avoid pain
than to gain pleasure that's right and
that's and and something else that came
to mind I'm sure you know I Joseph
Campbell says the treasure we seek is in
the cave we're afraid to go that's right
but like sometimes it isn't going to law
school sometimes it's literally can you
get still enough to let these things
have your attention exactly and deal
even with the existential yearning I I
my father I don't know why I could tell
you why it would just take too long he
asked me if I was afraid of God and and
in a fence I was like no because I've
done all this work to not be afraid of
God I was like isn't it interesting it's
it's so much more vulnerable and honest
and true not with my dad because I don't
want to give him the satisfaction but to
quietly go am I afraid of God and get
real about it like really look at that
instead of just going now he's love
everything's okay
right yeah there's a book on I think his
name was Douglas steer I can't remember
there's a little book on contemplation
by Merton and in the introduction he
says I like this he says if God is who I
think God is
um
so I think God has been finding God is
safe enough but what if God isn't at all
who I think God is and he is piercing
presence whole layers of who I thought I
was Fall Away who can risk it um but
likewise the very thought once said you
could spend your whole life and never
meet the person who's living your life
who can risk it but then if that's true
who can risk not doing it right yes can
I can I ask you isn't or shouldn't the
ego so for those of you I'm assuming
some people might be joining us for the
first time on this episode
we're dealing with some pretty Basics
like we have an ego which is our
personality our structure our
experiences our psychological self all
sort of it's I present that to you as
the character I'm sort of playing but
then there's my spiritual reality the
awareness upon which every all my
experiences are sort of writ
wouldn't my isn't it right that my ego
would be a little bit afraid of God
because of everything that will fall
away in it or her presence yes here's
the way I see it this is another false
self that you so yeah
um see what the ego is afraid the the
false self is not our personality God
wants us to have a healthy personality
because if our personality isn't healthy
we suffer and other people suffer and
say sure we should work on your
personality the false self is an
illusion the ego has about itself and
having the final say in who we are but
it doesn't have the final say who we are
it's the face or the openness to which
we are so one way I put it is when I say
myself myself there's the self of myself
and so I say I'm worried about myself
I'm ashamed of myself or I'm proud of
myself this is something I see but if
that's the self of myself who's the Maya
myself who's the me who sees me
now at one level I think the me who sees
me is the internalized self of myself
because I've internalized experiences
beliefs and so on but as it gets deeper
in silence or in love or suffering
the the my of myself becomes more and
more non-distinguished from the infinite
presence of God presencing herself as
the self of myself and by nothingness
without God which is unit of experience
that's also a romantic God Guru and self
yeah exactly that's exactly right right
so there is a deepest deepest self and I
I to go back to the fear though I
negotiate going
not to bring a Hot Topic into it but
sometimes when I I've had psychedelic
experiences and every time I jump off
that Cliff I have to go this will never
make sense to my ego because I'm about
to do something to it that will give it
no control so it will never go go for it
even though every time I get in that
space I enjoy it or I enjoy the merging
and the selflessness of it but does that
make sense it will I'll never be able to
convince my ego to merge with God
necessarily I feel like it it comes
along with the little willingness that's
as best as it can do does that make
sense
drugs are a little complicated in this
that done with Guidance with help it can
really be an expansion of ego it's still
ego right there's interior layers of ego
sure and of course many people
unfortunately goes the wrong way you
know it ends up destroying them but
putting that aside yes
no no no no no it's no I've opened all
that yeah so but let's say that any
experience where there's a sleeping off
into the surrendered place yes whether
it be intimacy or Solitude or that's
right vulnerable that's right and so
even though I know I can't find my way
to where my soul longs to go and stay
where I am see I think I can't stay in
the familiarity because I feel that it's
claustrophobic or one-dimensional
compared to this more spacious place I
want to go to and therefore this ego
that's trying to watch out for me
because if I'm not in control I'm not
safe that's what this aspect of the ego
believes uh that's always there there's
always that resistance but I do think
this I do think that over time
uh in different modalities of the leap
that uh the the ego can calm down and be
okay it can get used to being
transcended
if that makes sense it can get used to
being as your Homeland yeah and it's
even so it's even then it's translucent
to the deeper Place yeah you know I had
a big experience it was a psychedelic
experience and the way that I calmed
myself down to your point is I said I
promise we'll be back yeah and that
actually worked that was as close as I
could get to going like I'm going to
this strange place but I'll be back and
I've heard um do you know Muji he's a
yeah I like Muji too he goes he he talks
about non-dual awareness kind of like
visiting a room and he's like you take
your shoes off he goes leave leave your
shoes outside and he goes also leave
your mind outside but it but what I like
about our shoes being next to our mind
is we go into the room of no awareness
or whatever or no Oneness and it's
beautiful and it's peaceful and you kind
of know I'm gonna put my shoes back on
I'm gonna put my personality back on it
Comforts the ego to your point yeah it's
a story I haven't shared this in a long
time with people uh there's a story that
um that you've there's a school of Hindu
meditation
um that meets uh every morning with a
realized Yogi
and they're very dedicated so it means
like at five in the morning so they can
sit and go to work
and you go for the first meeting the
yogi is sitting there and all the people
are coming in
and the yogi introduces the practice he
said the practice is the inhale real
real real slow hold it for just a second
exhale real real real slow and say one
then inhale real real real real real
slow
exhale reel and say two all the way to
ten until you have the least distracting
thought you have to go back to one
are there any questions and he rings the
bell everyone bows and your sitting goes
like this one back to one one back to
one an hour later ring any questions you
raise your hand you say I didn't get
very far he said there's no rush we're
gonna do this every morning until we die
there's no rush
four four years later four years later
you're sitting there Faithfully one back
to one and all of it and you didn't see
this happening you get to two you get
excited about it you got to go back to
one and then you say to yourself oh my
God I'm not going to make it and that's
the point you never were yeah you see
but uh that idea of not making it right
something Wells up and gives itself to
you right right it can't be made right
they can't it's not fabricated or
achieved it's a granting I heard it
comes I don't want to interrupt I'm just
trying to load you with this one
if we let our achievements Define us and
or let our shame Define us I heard you
say they don't get the final words
please talk about that because I I'm a
four I'm a split right to the middle in
the Enneagram I'm a four and a three but
I'm a little bit more four than three
but I'm a four oh are you really oh I
can tell by your purple yeah
but I the achiever in me
or or the foreign that wants to be
special or different or not fit in like
I really hate being a member of a group
um but they don't get the last say on
Who We Are
now here's what it was it I see it Dan
Walsh teaching medieval philosophy at
the monastery he said to belong to a
contemplative Community is to Bear
witness of your worth what the
communities gathered for and it's not
about achieving anything you know it's a
communal surrender
to giving ourselves over to the mystery
that's giving itself to us unexplainably
with every breath and heart isn't it
hard though to vanish into a well you
know yes it's harder than hard you can't
you get a spiritual hernia trying to do
it you can't you can't make it happen
it's not like mysticism or bust yeah you
know yeah so what you do is you lean
into
it's like with all your heart leaning
into a receptive openness to what's imp
that's the thing about the spiritual
life too I think we get we've been
awakened to something which having
tasted it we know our life will be
forever and complete without it but
we're powerless by our own powers to
achieve it yes and so then we have to
depend on God
to guide us and take us to to ourselves
infinitely to himself infinitely and
that's practice the little willingness
it's the Willing it's the willingness
it's a state of willingness yeah and um
and so what it is is hard but it's not
it's it's like this it's hard to seek
this but having tasted it it's harder
not to do it yes because not to do it
you're selling yours it's like uh how I
put it too sometimes is that uh that God
is set as God created us in such a way
that nothing less than an infinite Union
with the infinite love of God will ever
be enough to put to rest the Restless
longings of our it's a setup yeah yeah
it's a setup and we're always trying to
pretend that if I just get more of this
it'll be enough say the thing about the
crow the more the shiny yeah you have
Martin says uh you said our minds are
like crows they pick up Everything That
Glitters no matter how uncomfortable our
nests get with all that metal in them
one more thing one more thing one more
thing yeah I caught myself thinking and
I can love myself in this maybe this is
the conversation I'll snap you know in
the good a good snap yeah but then I re
I went
it actually that whatever made me go
just this drive just drive to see James
and here's another way I see it too it
was just played by Eugene O'Neill I
think whether it's men and women are
meeting they're falling in love with
each other and they're planning to get
married
and he says that he says I know I need
to tell you something here because I'm
wearing a mask
she says you are she's will take it off
he said I can't take it off if I took it
off you'd leave me
um geez but don't you understand now
that I know you're wearing a mask if you
don't take it off we don't have a real
relationship
so in a fundamental and a moment of
existential courage he lowers the mass
she sees his true face when she leaves
him put some ass back she comes back
like a mask wearing a mask but what true
love is this true love is this what a
horrible play yeah yeah there's been a
lot of relationships in that way I'm
wearing my mask you wear your mask well
that's what ramnath says I'll tell you
you I'll ignore that you're wearing a
spacesuit
so but how it works is this way I think
this is married love or intimacy uh
you're wearing a mask I'm afraid to take
it off see all right
and so the other person says you know
don't I don't want you to take it off
until you're ready to take it off yeah
because I love you matter of fact let me
adjust it for you a little bit that's
right and the more you're accepted and
knowing that you're wearing the mask the
Masters becoming translucent and your
face shines with the mask and real love
is offering that to each other a lot of
psychotherapies about this too yes I
think seriously safety really yes you're
convinced that you are what's wrong with
you yes see I do I summarized I saw a
great therapist for many years and what
he said to me most was who cares yeah
and yeah beautiful who cares but he was
funny that's right who cares that's
right he goes who cares yeah and it's
actually a great question who who cares
because then go on yeah who cares
no I know it's true it's what the owl is
asking too
hey weirdos we talk a lot about anxiety
and depression on the show and I've
personally struggled with both and I've
had friends whose lives have been
completely transformed uh by ketamine
therapy guided ketamine therapy because
sometimes it's not as simple as a new
therapist or exercise meditation or Diet
sometimes you need something new to
unlock your brain and maybe that thing
is ketamine therapy from mind Bloom
there's a new tool to improve your
mental health at home ketamine therapy
and mind Bloom is the leader in at home
ketamine therapy helping safely help
thousands of people overcome their
anxiety and their depression unlike
traditional talk therapy ketamine Works
quickly and doesn't have the unpleasant
side effects of traditional
antidepressants in fact in a study of
over 1200 mind Bloom clients 89 reported
improvements in their anxiety and
depression after only two sessions I
personally have done guided ketamine
therapy I can swear by it it is
incredible it is helpful it helped me me
just reframe my world it's such a
powerful tool and right now mind Bloom
is offering our listeners a hundred
dollars off your first six session
program when you sign up at
mindbloom.com
ymiw and use promo code ymiw take the
first step and break free from your
anxiety and depression with mind Bloom
you can go to mindbloom.com
ymiw like you made it weird and use
promo code
ymiw those are the letters mindbloom.com
ymiw all right and did you know secondly
did you know we're eating and drinking
roughly a credit card's worth of plastic
a week when I first read that I was like
a year maybe it's a week that's right
the products that we use every day are
ultimately contaminating our water
supply generating hundreds of micro
hundreds of microplastics that we end up
ingesting luckily our friends at Blue
land are set out to do something about
it to eliminate the need for single-use
plastic in the products we reach for the
most like hand soap did you know that an
estimated 5 billion plastic hand soap
and cleaning bottles are thrown away
each year and if that's not bad enough
most cleaning formulas are 90 water
which is heavy to ship leading to
excessive carbon emissions not to
mention the nasty ingredients in them
like chlorine and ammonia but blue land
is inventing cleaning Essentials is
Reinventing cleaning Essentials
Essentials to be better for you and the
planet by offering endlessly refillable
cleaning products with a beautiful
cohesive design it's one of my favorite
things about it the bottles look really
cool on your countertop that look great
and are better for you and the planet
just fill the bottles with water that's
mostly what they are anyway drop in the
tablets and wait for them to dissolve
hand soap toilet bowl cleaner laundry
tablets with clean ingredients you can
feel good about and know you're doing
something good for the planet and help
us all eat a little less plastic no more
bulky Cleaning Supplies on your grocery
run and refills start at just 225 I
recommend their clean ascent controls
kit which has everything you need to get
started and comes in beautiful light
sense like Iris Agave fresh lemon and
Eucalyptus mint blue land has an offer
just for weirdos get 15 off your first
purchase of any product and get cleaning
products that I love the look of and
love that they're good for you and the
planet to get 15 off your first door to
go to blueland.com
ymiw you won't want to miss this
blueland.com ymiw that's blueland.com
ymiw all right everybody let's get back
to the living wizard James Finley
I it's funny the thing that brought me
to to you was father Boyle and he quotes
you in in one of his books and it just
blew me away
and we spoke about it briefly you and I
over Zoom once
um
you and I are comfortable using all
these religious words I think it'll fold
even more people into the conversation
if we talk a little bit about this a God
I believe in a God who protects me from
nothing but sustains me in all things in
all things
I said to you when I when I heard that I
was like oh I I didn't it's like you say
it's like the Poetry of the mystics I go
I didn't know I needed that I needed
just that you know what I mean I picked
it up and I was like oh it's exactly the
shape of my pocket I had this hole
because so much atheism
um I had a brief for anti-atheism after
my wife left me she had an affair my
first wife
and of course I mean it's like the
Playbook you either become extremely
religious or you lose your religion I
went with the second one that's true and
I think that the message of that and
maybe you can fold it into your own life
or bring in your own experience
but father Boyle makes the point you
know people pass around the email
forwards this is the story of the guy
who was going to the World Trade Center
on 9 11 but he saw an old friend and
they went to breakfast and then he his
life was spared and these words get
passed around and we love those stories
it's a little bit of a star moving story
and then we go but what about the 3 000
people who who went to work that day and
when I heard your quote
it that seemed like the beginning of a
salve for a new way of looking at
Divinity not as a bodyguard who believes
a lot of the same things we believe a
good life a long life a comfortable life
a flourishing life like a successful
Western productive uh affluent life is
valuable but like can you speak a little
bit to that
going through a lot at you just then oh
no it's fine it's good
uh I mean as I say first of all we use
God language you know in a way it's true
I mean God there's a truth to that
there's a way to understand that Abba
Father God takes care of us watches over
us and and so on so this is the truth to
that
but there's another layer of it
and every trauma Survivor knows this I'm
a drama Survivor
every trauma Survivor knows whatever it
means that God takes care of us it
doesn't mean that God takes care of us
and the way I put it here in Los Angeles
tonight their little girls are going to
be incested again
and no one's going to stop it God is not
going to stop their little boy is going
to be beaten again again God's not going
to stop it no one stop me no one stop my
father from beating me
many times actually until the day until
I left home actually 18 years old
see so and this is the mystery of the
cross the whole mystery of the Cross is
that whatever it means that God takes
care of us it doesn't mean that God
prevents the the cruel or the UN how I
put it this way there's no place on this
Earth so pure or innocent or safe that
the cruel the ugly the destructive and
the unfair just might not find you and
bring you down every trauma Survivor
knows that this would be a recipe for
despair if it were not knowing in your
heart through faith that the darkness of
this world has no refuge from the love
that transcends it and permeates it
unexplainably in all directions forever
transcends and permians it transcends
and permit and doesn't take it away God
depends on us to do our best to prevent
it and to take it away when it occurs
but grounded in the peace is not
dependent on the outcome of our efforts
because maybe I'm not going to be able
to take it away but that's not the point
that's at the point so I am sustained
honest explainably Come What May and the
whole mystery of the cross I think is
the Christian matter of every religion
has its own metaphor for this for the
Buddhists of great death and so on and
uh so that's how I see it you know
that's why people often would come to me
for therapy
trauma survivors because they wanted
their spirituality to be resource in
their therapy
and so as you lay back the layers
uh getting close to the herding place
and then how I put it is that when we
risk sharing What Hurts the Most in the
presence of someone who will not invade
us or abandon us we can learn not to
invade or abandon ourself you can be
reparented in love where someone just
treats you the way you deserve to be
treated from the day you were born
that's true even deeper when we risk
sharing What Hurts the Most and the
presence of someone would not invade us
or abandon us we can unexpectedly come
upon within ourselves where Jesus is
called the Pearl a great price the
Invincible preciousness of yourself in
your Brokenness Merton says there is
that in us that is not subject to the
brutalities of our own will no matter
how badly you trash yourself you can't
do anything to this because it belongs
to God and to find that Pearl shining
bright in the broken place and then to
learn to live by it and draw from it to
touch the hurting places that's one way
I understand the healing path and as
Leonard Cohen said the cracks or what
helps us get to the parole exactly the
light shines out falling up that's right
exactly doing it wrong not doing it
right yeah but that Pearl isn't James
after a good cup of coffee right
the Pearl was in James being articulate
or on or funny right I mean that's true
because there's a temptation as you're
speaking to go wait this is I can be the
pearl of great price it's not it there's
a disappointment a trunk boat Rampage
says Enlightenment is the ego's ultimate
disappointment I I share a story in the
book that when I first went to the
monastery I read Merton for four years
sustain me through the drama a severe
PTSD dissociative disorder I didn't even
know I had it I just was that way all my
life I'm not trying to be funny but how
could you right yeah I started when I
was three years old yeah
so when I went to the monastery
I couldn't believe I was going to sit
with Thomas Merton for my spiritual
director you know and I was right out of
high school did it just happen you
didn't have to like wait in the Merton
line oh no well yeah he was novice
Master yeah and so he he spiritual
direction to all the novices because you
entered for six months as a posture and
two years as a novice before you took
temporary vows so he was a novice Master
to help you discern if it was your
vocation or not so he introduced me to
the mystics and my own experiences that
I was having he helped me understand
them
and so but when I wanted to see him
because of my trauma I had issues with
authority figures so and when I started
to talk I was hyperventilating a bit
nervous and he wanted to know what's
wrong and I I said my voice was shaking
I said I'm scared because you're Thomas
Merton
and I was so embarrassed because I
wanted him to think well of me and Harry
saw the me that I didn't want anyone to
know about him including me the mask
came up yeah and he said this to me he
said I worked on the farm the pig Barn
the big farm like The Prodigal Son yeah
and he said every day I want you to
finish afternoon work early before
vespers
come in here knock on the door sit down
and tell me one thing that happened at
the pig Barn that day I remember inside
the voice that I can do that and I'd
knock on the door and he'd put the
typewriter aside he was always working
on a book and he remembered all this
like household number five how's her
foot and he would tell pig jokes and and
it level the playing field then it
opened up this whole conversation about
mystical Union with God and mystical
longings and he led me to the teachings
of them I'll never forget that moment
uh about Mercy you know that he gave you
something you could do you could do
hyperventilating yeah it was it was so
uh
empathically tenderhearted yeah it just
opened the door like that just I was so
touched like that it's gorgeous I was
sitting with my friends the gungers and
they have a 12 year old daughter and I
won't give you the whole story but but
she said uh something about JK Rowling I
don't know you know JK sort of got
canceled uh for saying something that
people perceived as transphobic I know
that's right I don't know the story
that's why I'm being delicate with my
language I I'm not taking a stand see
how careful I have to be but um the the
12 year old girl went I don't like JK
Rowling she stinks or whatever and the
parents were like why and and like so
many of us she didn't know why she just
knew that that's what was happening but
then this is the mistake I think I made
I went well you know at this point in
her life what am I doing I go belonging
matters so much more than being informed
and taking the correct stance on JK
Rowling she's just trying to make tribe
and I and I thought of you because I've
heard you speak about that going instead
of saying tell me one thing that
happened at the pigs I went well really
you just want an identity so badly
you'll say anything it's true to belong
and what of course did the girl say she
said I don't want to talk about this
anymore and and went away you know not
not just to me it wasn't true it wasn't
that good of a story that she wouldn't
stop at and walked away she just sort of
locked up but Merton
heard you I've heard um Rupert Spira say
I hear people calling out in the woods
it's my job to go into the woods and
find them and then walk them out not
yell from outside the woods you're just
trying you're 12 you're trying to have
identity like that's what I was doing
that's really true
yeah
they say in therapy you know the
therapist makes the a social response to
the social responses advice or an
opinion everyone's got an opinion yeah
the way I see why don't you try this
yeah yeah the a social response is um uh
you share what you were sharing whatever
it is and the therapist might say
something like um
well I want to ask you a question so I
understand you better
I get the fact that what I quite
understand is this could you help me
more with that right and you the person
just said then the therapist might say
something like let me say it back so
edit it for me so we're together yeah I
have another question and little by
little by little we get close to the
hurting place and we can tell because
you'll tear up where you'll laugh when
you say something sad yeah then the
therapist says you know if we don't get
close enough to touch it it'll keep
festering but if we move too fast it
won't be safe in here nothing will
happen wow therefore how can we learn
here Define an alliance that'll make it
safe for you to do what you came here to
do wow and uh it's and I think more we
can learn in therapy how to relate to
everybody that way you know when I
benefit from it we have a partner or as
somebody and we can kind of learn that
art yeah of uh yeah this whole time
you've been speaking Val is a master of
what you're saying being a safe place
where I can take my mask off she's a I
call her a love genius I'm reminded also
when someone has a delusion I'm Napoleon
the classic or I'm Christ although let's
not get started on whether or not we're
Christ they'll lock us up
um but if someone says I'm Napoleon
the first step is to say
uh you are Napoleon I I've heard this
that you're supposed to meet them not
not immediately go you're James Finley
you're not Napoleon wake up it's 2023
like that's the wrong energy it's not
safe like you said it's not safe to go
towards it because all you've met is
resistance which is just kind of
empowering the delusion
yeah first of all it's in layers now you
say the person who thinks he's Napoleon
the person who
who knows he's Napoleon yeah the the
person who thinks he's Napoleon and
worries about it goes to therapy he's
neurotic yeah the person who knows he's
Napoleon
and worries about the therapist because
the therapist isn't bright enough to see
that they're Napoleon is psychotic yes
yes
and uh and and so they live in a castle
in the sky and the psychiatrist collects
the rent
so you're right because if the person
really thinks like the therapist should
write on the notepad delusions of
grandiosity it's mental illness so
you're exactly right you wouldn't say no
you're not
you would form an alliance with the
person and go from there on the
treatment plan with that similarly to
for spirituality my ego says I'm Pete
Holmes I'm a comedian I am successful I
am tall I am from Boston and I feel the
voice of God saying okay let's start
there right I feel the same gentleness
when we talk about the things that
aren't working what what tell me my wife
used to tell me I'd go on these Retreats
so sometimes it would be a lot of people
in these Retreats yes and just a lot of
people Express this kind of I don't know
what it is like reverence or yes it's
kind of like this and she there's a
story in the gospels whereas a woman had
a flow of blood and she said if I would
Touch the Hem of His robes I shall be
made whole so when I would walk through
the door from a retreat you would say
are there were there many hammers there
yeah
once I was I was at the end of repeat I
was autographing books at the end I felt
something of the cup of my pants there
was a guy kneeling on the floor behind
me touching the cup having the Himalaya
and his wife was taking his picture to
him yeah
that's the funniest thing that's a great
Sam Cooke Song too I think it's an old
gospel song but if I could just Touch
the Hem of it yeah exactly but Sam Cooke
does it yeah but I know I know that is
brilliant and then you had the person
that you could come to and sort of laugh
about it and like with your wife the
great thing about her she was so
grounded in this this was our marriage
really we both had a trauma history she
had a lot of AAA stuff and it's just
somebody where you're just uh
just yourself yes
and it's not a function that people see
you through because of what it helps
them do when you do that gift it helps
them yeah mental health or I mean it's
important it's but then there's
something deeper that's not reducible to
a role that we play it helps people and
there's something like innermost about
it and I think that's
the ground of the Soul kind of Val is
you would love Val I hope you get to
meet her I hope she gets to meet you too
but she's I'm top down and she's bottom
up so I come home and I tell her the
world is an illusion and or whatever it
might be whatever thing I'm playing with
and she goes and also uh you seem kind
of stressed out maybe let's get a
blanket on you and like get on the couch
and that seems so
non-productive or whatever or let's
dance she might put on music and be like
let's just dance or or let's make dinner
let's smell oil and and garlic let's I
know that it sounds like I'm painting
her as like a matriar or like a classic
woman those just happen to be the
examples that come to mind but what a
gift that's what I mean I I see a
a gentleness I'm being I feel pursued
because that makes by the Divine yeah
yeah I feel it looking for me and it'll
get me either way so when we talk about
things that don't work uh we're addicted
to our phones we can't stop being
productive or email or money there's
even a Grace hidden in that because it
doesn't work talk about skimming on the
surface isn't there something about
so let's think about a future where Ai
and technology is giving you everything
you want we already have it bringing
whatever food you desire whatever movie
you'd like to watch whatever music you'd
like to hear isn't there kind of a a
little smart bomb of Grace in there too
that it goes it's not gonna work I would
say this
it may or may not come close to giving
everything that we want but it won't
give us what we need yes because the sum
total of the Gathering Together of what
we want
is qualitatively impoverished compared
to the depth of the need
which has to do about love or presence
or fulfillment or Surrender or gratitude
you know we so that's the Dowry of our
soul in a way and uh so that's the thing
about that I think this is what I'm
trying to teach my daughter is she goes
I want ice cream and I'm like yeah ice
cream yesterday and she's like but I
want ice cream again and we go well
that's the want monster there's always
another one she buys into that yeah she
oh she doesn't buy it exactly absolutely
not I'll give her the ice cream if she
at least tolerates me saying at least
let's notice that this is a never-ending
Thing Once for my oldest daughter she
was maybe five and I stopped to go to an
ice cream we were having ice cream
and she said I like ice cream more than
you do
so I tried to explain to her I said
honey you can't say that how you'd have
to know how much I know in order you
know you're trying to turn into a
five-year-old yes it's nothing doesn't
make any sense and she just said she
just keeps beating her ice cream yes
like
we're back at the table me going well
belonging is more important than me and
that's what I think whenever we're uh
in the presence of someone and meet them
wherever they are
it helps us
it just helps us so much can I join them
where they are and walk with them can I
it touches us let's talk a little bit
about that because I told you I'm
studying A Course in Miracles we talk
about that briefly and one of the things
I love about it because I need this is
it reminds us that our Salvation is
together it's it's in the other I I'm
like the Merton thing I told you off
Mike that I don't know if I'm a
contemplative or if I'm just an
introvert and there's something about
there's a line in the course that says
you can't know your own Perfection until
you see the perfection in everyone who
is made like you and I was and and
there's also like Richard Rohr says
I don't know of a personal salvation
that's a true salvation that's just you
like that's not that's not how it works
it's in everybody thing can you talk
about our Salvation hiding in in one
another it yeah I say sorry I do that
yeah
I love this quote and Merton he was
lying in the middle of the night and he
had insomnia
and uh he's lying there in the dark he
says suddenly the bed becomes an altar
and in a distant City somewhere
someone's suddenly able to pray
and then he says perhaps the people
who perhaps the people whose lives we
will touch the most deeply are people we
will not meet until after we are dead
and you know that Hindu Mythic image of
indra's net
it's like yeah imagine a big fishing net
and each knot of the net is a diamond
yeah and each Diamond reflects all the
other diamonds yeah so we're woven into
each so it's like way if I'm suffering
my suffering doesn't belong to me my
suffering is I'm woven into the
suffering of everybody and we're woven
together in our blessedness and we're
woven together in our suffering and so
we're woven together in the
interconnectedness of each other like
siblings of the infinite you know and uh
yeah Community right it's beautiful I've
also heard that's how God is suffering
this is a Richard line but with us
through us and as us exactly that's a
comforting when God is sustaining you
when he's beating your mother or beating
you when you're a little boy
God was a part of that suffering not a
spectator to it is that correct
oh this retrieve this recently
and I have this something that I say
poetically
and I say that even if you burn to death
fire is trustworthy you know even if you
drown Waters trustworthy even if a
stranger carries you off to do terrible
things that persons your misguided
brother or sister and mystically it's
true right because we're beyond the body
it's Eternal right
and afterwards someone contacted me and
they were very upset when I said that
because his daughter and wife burned to
death
when I said fire is trustworthy it was a
see a triggering event and Trauma is
anything that reminds you of the trauma
that's right even though in other ways
it's completely different the autonomic
nervous system will re-experience yeah
you've seen my dog bark when I'm in the
room yeah so so we had a lovely talk
about that and uh because the way I put
it too is that uh when someone's in a
traumatized state
to speak about their trauma and
spiritual terms is deeply disrespectful
to that person and they can tell you
don't understand them and the only
authentic response is I'm so sincerely
sorry that you're having to go through
this see that they know that they're not
alone that's the thing that they know
they're not alone with it well that's a
little bit Napoleon isn't it I I'm not
saying they're delusional or or
psychotic but they're lost in their
grief and it's not helpful for you to go
yeah but how I put it to I put this in
the Memoir when Maureen died
from us here I would literally walk
around this way screaming out loud like
I loved you so much I loved you so I'm
not happy I wasn't happy here
at all and uh just wanted to die really
but then over time so you could say I
was in a delusional but it was my it
wasn't it was my life right okay so
because the intensity and density of the
pain can Eclipse access to the deeper
place you can't get past it and then
over time it started to shift for me
where I said you know it's not that I
loved you so much you're dead and I
still love you
and I believe that you still love me
from a depth of love I can barely
comprehend you and I talked about this
over and over over the years I share
with people that we would sit out there
and have buff an hour on the porch and I
was always riding with my fountain pen
and and uh she would say I'm going to go
in for she'd usually go in first we'd
have dinner and better and uh and I say
I'll be in in 10 minutes
and it was like a little ritual 20
minutes later she'd come out I'd be
writing and she'd look at her wrist
touch her wrist watch go like this and I
put the cap on my pen and she would
always come out right when I was the
right at the verge of a deep thought yes
yes and the thought would come to me the
day might come I would give anything to
have you come out and interrupt me at
the edge of a deep thought and that day
has come because she's dead
and uh and and so that's the thing we
ride the waves we're stuck in a certain
place but if we sit with it the stuck
place has a certain uh
previously unrecognized openings in it
you know and uh by intimately walking
with the hurting place with insight and
patience and courage and listening to it
we can find a way back into the light
again and I and I say too if we find our
way back into the light not everybody
does
but if we do we know how important it is
not to forget what we learned in the
dark about suffering don't delete it
don't delete it don't dismiss it because
that's your trigger that's your touch
point of empathy with those who are lost
in the dark what a gift you are
Partners right exactly and I I think of
that all the time I go what you semi if
I do something I don't like
um it's usually something small but I I
lose some Battle of Will and I do the
easy thing or the the whatever
sometimes I comfort myself and I go what
use am I if I don't if I can't relate to
someone who occasionally eats too much
fried chicken or whatever it might have
been what use am I if I'm just over here
I don't even touch the ground there was
this nun I used to see in therapy and uh
share this thing about none are supposed
to smoke yes she had anxiety disorder
actually and then so she smoked in her
room should she put towels under the
door open up the window and she'd take a
deep Dragon Blood like this and she felt
really bad that she smoked she was in
therapy wanted to yeah I said well it
would be good if you could wouldn't
smoke because it's not good for your
health but I have another suggestion
uh next time you're leaning toward the
window take a very deep drag and blow it
out the window as incense to the Divine
Mercy that's infinitely in love with you
as you smoke your cigarette right and
the smoke will go better yeah she'd like
that that reminds me of Father boy I
think of him all the time he goes
I don't believe God has a plan for you
meaning the plan would be quit smoking I
believe God is too busy delighting in
you to have a plan for you yeah that's
very true isn't that good that's true
and like you're it just you hear it you
go yes you have another way I put it too
is um
sometimes when there is something going
on we know it's not good for us like the
physical thing with thing or sexuality
or alcohol whatever it is is we're
compromising our wholeness and we can't
stop yeah
is that there is a stance of active
waiting
so active waiting is an indifference or
passivity I'll just keep doing it I
don't care but you wait in a willingness
to do it when the grace to given you to
do it you'll do it and it's not there
yet and the fact is not the area I can
learn not to do violence or the
fragility of my waiting because God
isn't waiting for me to do it before God
starts loving me God's infinitely in
love with me and my inability to stop
doing that that's why I share with
people in the Merton talks imagine your
issue in life as a temper and you're
always working on your temper in your
last act on this Earth in the hospital
is you throw a bedpan and then you die
I say this is regrettable because when
you go to hit somebody and you're hoping
for a better exit but what really
matters most is you through it knowing
God's infinitely in love with people who
don't throw bed pads God's infinitely in
love with people who do yeah and if you
throw it that way yes and exhale the
enzymes O'Connor says she had this
vision of at the end of time of all the
all the the fools of the world leading
Humanity into the gates of paradise and
the fools of the world are jumping up
and down turning somersaults and so on
followed by the righteous concern
whether or not they're singing on key
the same idea well that goes back to the
breath we were saying the ego would
rather scan the breath and wand it down
and yeah and we don't want we don't
we don't want
I tried to do this joke on stage I go my
God is love
which is boring it's so boring it's like
a friend who doesn't talk [__] I go out
to him at a bar of course I'm joking but
I'm like ah did you see what Andy did
and he's like
and he is my beloved he's my treasure
yeah he's my treasure and I'm like this
sucks you know like you kind of if
you're being really honest if I'm being
really honest I'll leave you out of it I
can catch myself wanting that old school
God that goes with us not with us that's
every sport game of sport game that's
every athletic event that's every Oscar
night we want winners and losers yeah
and and that's Strife like the political
scene today exactly there's a political
scene today and so somehow there are all
there are those who are sometimes I put
it this way do you want to live in the
truth
then believe what I believe we can sing
a hymn of praise to God together but if
you differ from me this much or this
much an error differ from me this much
or this much complete disagree with me
you're completely an error and may God
have mercy on your soul and God won't
because this was your chance I gave it
to you and they like that they don't
they there's people who really walk
around like that there's a line I just
read it in A Course in Miracles where it
says even when your brother is wrong
tell him he's right because if you're if
you're judging and labeling what he's
saying you're from your ego as well but
look past that and see the true self
like what are you recognize in him
you'll recognize in yourself actually I
want to say two layers of that yeah
you know in rigerian therapy they they
talk about
um self-congruence
and so the rogerian Triad Carl Rogers
client-centered therapy is unconditional
positive regard no matter what you tell
me it won't lessen my respect for you
the next is uh empathy I can join you I
hear you saying you're not alone and the
third one is self-congruence I'll always
be honest with you
and so you would say so but it's always
in a respectful way like quite honestly
when you talk like that I'm concerned
about you that has respect in it and
that's very different than shooting from
the hip and correcting the person right
it's completely different it's
interesting but we can't we love doing
that I mean
rain Wilson did the podcast I actually
liked it but I said tenants instead of
tenants and he corrected me and I
thought about it later and I was like
isn't it interesting how vulnerable how
fragile we are
tell me what you think about this tell
me so much of humor and I think I think
there's a kindness for your humor as as
Mike Birbiglia keeps calling me like
he's on I shouldn't say another comedian
see only my friends know my phone's
always on do not disturb so they call me
twice and then I think it's my wife I
think there's some some issue they know
how to do that yeah it's annoying uh I'm
so sorry tell me about it I listen to
your comedy and there's a there's a
kindness to us funny but some Canadians
uh by Norm Macdonald I think he's
brilliant yeah but dark yeah yeah for
sure so dark yeah what is it about
meanness that makes us laugh I know you
say the meanest thing there's something
there's almost like a release
to feel laugh about it yes to lessen the
discomfort we have it but it's still
done in such a way there's an edge to it
like you really wonder yeah I I have a
lot of thoughts about this I I say on
the show all the time even the even take
your pick Thomas Merton some holy person
occasionally got on the train and was
like I don't know why but I hate the
back of this guy's head it just flashes
through you I hate this guy's head and
when a comedian who's in a status
position he's under lights so his mask
is presumably off he's lit he's loud
he's in an alpha position and he uses
his alphanus to lower himself and tell
you about his shortcomings even if it's
in ugliness because we have a social
contract to not be ugly and he goes
that's what it's like up here one time
I was stoned and I don't do a lot of
drugs I I don't know I have this piety
alarm go off that's so silly forgive me
for that but I was stoned this is years
ago and I was like oh my God stem comedy
is is act accurately and honestly
reporting what it feels like to be
floating around in this map so when I
say
I used to have a joke where I go I hate
my girlfriend's friends I just hate them
I already have a I have a girl what do I
need these these women telling me these
stories and I would and I'd go get out
of here Bridget I'm full up like I'm
good and I talk about I hate my
girlfriend's parents I don't I can't do
this joke I couldn't even post on my
Instagram because my in-laws follow me
now but there wasn't honesty to the
shallowness of it or whatever no that's
good no that's really true right and
then we laugh at our shallowness that's
right because it's a way of it's Shadow
work it's like
it's okay and and you can tell that I
love myself even despite this maybe not
Norm I don't know some guys aren't going
the self-love route but I'm going like
join me in celebrating how absurd this
is that's really true years ago I saw a
card I used to get New Yorker magazine
all the cartoon sure
his husband and wife talking and she's
trying to cheer him up you can tell he's
down
like feeling and she's to cheer him off
she says sweetheart listen
she said of course you're going to feel
like a failure if you keep comparing
yourself to men who are successful
you laugh because it's great yeah well
comedy is this is not my theory but
somebody did a very expensive thing
that's a benign violation so a wife
isn't supposed to say that but it's not
she's not cutting his head off with
shears that's too far that's really true
so I'm not supposed to say I hate my
girlfriend's parents that's benign
though because they're not here that's
why comedy gets very different when
there's a person in the wheelchair in
the front row that's right Everything
Changes it does and that's what happened
with social media I make a joke like
that and I just said I can't share
because my in-laws will see it so comedy
came out of the clubs and now all the
stuff that's supposed to be taboo or
it's like a little like oh we're in a
nightclub in Amsterdam and we're just
kind of being naughty and isn't it
Wicked and it's fun or performance Arty
it changes when that that same joke
Scrolls through your feet at 11 A.M on a
Tuesday and you're in your office the
context is gone that's true I have a lot
of thoughts about this yeah that is true
well boy I've I'm so enjoying this
conversation I don't want it and and
you've you've uh you've given us so much
I just want to make sure I don't forget
anything I absolutely wanted to ask you
oh this is what I wanted to get this is
this will be a nice way to close when we
were talking about God earlier I started
asking you this I was worried that some
people might back away because they
start going old man in the sky most
people that listen to this podcast no we
don't mean that
um or if that or if we do that that
that's a metaphor
when you say God just to include people
what are we talking about what are the
definitions or the images or the quotes
or whatever it may be that isn't just
the Arbiter of who goes to hell and
having all the classic stuff that just
rightfully turns so many people away
from they they'd rather skim on the
surface if going under means there's a
Tormentor down there
well
I guess I would say that for me my
understanding of God is uh
the god that's revealed in a
contemplative understanding of the
scriptures
and also in the philosophical theology
of uh uh a Christian tradition done
scotus Thomas Aquinas the mystics and so
looking at it in that but there there
will be analogous parallels in taoism in
in the path of yoga namaste in the path
of the of the Buddha uh the Divinity the
phenomenal World boundless in all
directions and so on so I always say
that in the word god
is a word that we use for the Infinity
of presence
that there's a there's a beginningless
endless boundaryless in Infinity of
presence itself being itself yeah in
other words it could be being also yeah
and say this and then ultimately
speaking just one thing is happening
that this infinite presence is
presencing itself that is pouring itself
out and endlessly giving itself away in
and as the gift and the Miracle of the
intimate immediacy of your very presence
the presence of others in the presence
of all things in our communal
nothingness without God so God is like a
poetic sound like a word for the
generosity and then they say when it
comes to you
so that's true of stones and trees and
stars and the world is God's body that
is bodying forth this love that's
uttering it into being so when God
created you as a person
um God creates this persons unlike
stones and fees and stars God creates
you would that when God created
there's a before creation there's no
capacity for loving God
because God is octopus clarissimus the
overflowing fullness of Love itself so
if you have a glass of water and you
pour water in it the water is
overflowing there's no capacity for
water in the cup so there's no capacity
for loving God therefore God creates the
capacity to receive the infinite love of
God and God creates a cop pox day and
that's you God creates a capacity the
Overflow the Overflow because of God and
so God creates you as the Beloved
is the one to whom God can completely
infinitely give the infinity so that's
what I say the the generosity to the
infinite is infinite and we are the
generosity of God and that's what I mean
by that's my sense of God and then when
we fall and stumble
then I know the acceptance of my
fragility that when love touches
Suffering The Suffering turns love into
mercy
and uh so to me that's that's God am I
and I that's that's my understanding and
your experience I have to imagine yes
when you spelunk in you find a lover not
a Tormentor yeah yeah in other words I
another thing I think is so important is
that if we're talking about the topic
God
that's one thing I do is there this
being called God and you think that's
true now let's argue about it but I
think in reality it's not a topic it's a
word that you use to express something
you've tasted
that you can't explain its innermost and
it matters very much and then how can
you walk by it and live by it and share
it that's how Jesus that's Jesus as the
Buddha that's Muhammad on the night of
death to become it you become it to
recognizes I've heard God doesn't love
us we are God's love we are God's love
right and are nothing as well that's the
Paradigm we are God's love it or
nothingness without God
and uh it's that unit of it's that unit
of experience and then we're to see it
shining out through the details like it
gives itself silently in prayer but he
gives itself in the in the unfolding of
the day you know like the endless
variations of this ultimate unfolding
and we can learn to experience it
breathe it walk by it and live it and
the contemplative way of life and when
you were yelling in this apartment
sitting I heard you say you sat with
your pain you listened to it it sounds
like you gave it space you let it
express itself I'm wondering how you
injured yourself back yeah well I would
say first mystically I would say the
language of the cry God's God was the
Infinity of my pain
God was the Infinity of my pain because
the mystery of this love God so loved
the world that God became our pain
to be one of this God's response to us
and our dilemma is to be identified with
us as precious and in our dilemma and so
God seen God was the Infinity of my pain
sustaining me unexplainedly when I
couldn't find anywhere to hold on to
like that that's what I it came to you
as pain it was yes it was pain and at
one level it was just Pam what I mean is
I was I was in a traumatized State
actually yeah because it re-triggered my
childhood trauma yeah and it all came
like that but then I I believe that as I
uh because it's how I live my whole life
uh that's what I mean by Spirit system
nothing even as we're sustained in all
things and uh then little by little by
little I emerged into a more grounded
place it's not that's not dualistically
other than the pain itself yeah I mean
this all interwoven it was their action
there was it friends was it
well
I think for me it was
part of it I just sorted it out myself
but also uh my two I'm too very close to
my two daughters
and they came to visit me regularly they
see me every weekend and I'm close to
both of them and um I really sensed in
their love for me it's like life goes on
life goes on and uh
uh and I I need to move on and I I and I
know of Maureen if I died first
uh it would have been the same with
Maureen I think she would have been lost
and bereft but she knows that life life
goes on
you know and I also think for myself you
know I'm 80 years old May 30th I'm not
stuck here forever
and so I'll disappear soon enough yeah
too and so I just uh it was so big for
me because I'm a trauma therapist yes
and I I've known trauma I know what
trauma is so I knew what was happening
and also my therapy helped me just know
how to work with my trauma how to
integrate it and contextually internally
yeah I could Within Myself I could see
what I was doing tell me a little bit
about death just to close feels
appropriate here we are at the end talk
about death
because it's see I I don't feel that
fear or that Panic Vanishing or going
home again Ramon Omar she keeps coming
up when he was dying he said don't be
silly where could I go I heard you say
the same thing about Maureen
um as best as we can
just with no Stakes or judgment what do
you what do you make of death oh here's
my yes my senses is is that and I put it
in the book because I when she was dying
I said this because we should talk about
it yeah when I was in the monastery uh
an old lady brother died and Martin was
talking to the novices about death
he said it's very helpful to know that
when we die we don't go anywhere when we
die we don't orbit the earth a few times
and take off and go to God
his scripture says in God we live and
move and have our being we're living our
life in the vast interiority of God all
the dead are here all the angels are
here and we don't see the dead for the
same reason we don't see God
but in deep meditative States you can
see the dead meaning realize the one
that the ancestors the Oneness so I I so
what I think then death is how I put it
is that when we're born onto the Earthly
plane how I put it poetically God
exhales the Infinity of herself as us in
our life and we're on this Earth through
time for a very short time basically to
learn how to love basically and in God's
good time God inhales and we return back
home to this love they miktail the
Mystic said that God revealed to her
that he has so freely chosen to be so
hopelessly in love with her that he
honestly doesn't know if he could handle
being god without her and she said take
me home with you I'll be your physician
forever
and so what I think mystical death is on
this Earth we die to everything less
than love and having the authority to
name who we are and if we that walk we
can do that to such a refinement that in
some deep sense when we die nothing will
happen because we've already died
if you die before you die you won't die
yeah exactly so the Mystic is in
somebody who says listen to what I've
experienced the message says look what
Love's done to me see there's nobody
left
and when there's nobody left who dies
but but another very real level I'm
going to die right it's very real right
right it's already in the mail it's on
its way that's what my friend David
nicktrin says he goes if it's all one
whose headache is this yeah which I I
think about that all the time there's a
little quote by ramdas I keep it up pure
Maureen I keep used to keep her sayings
yeah this is don't be afraid of death is
like taking off a tight shoe at the end
of the day yeah and mirabai star said
ramdas said that yeah because Maureen I
used to listen to ramdas yeah
I'm going to dork out here he's actually
quoting
Elijah who is a channeled disembodied
being who said that because he asked the
woman miss something kind of guessed I'm
just Dorking out what about death and he
said don't worry it's like taking off a
tight shoe
now you can have a little footnote and
go that's that's the deepest yeah it's
really true it's so beautiful though
what what you have such a way and I'm
just I think everybody's really happy
they tuned in for this I know I am I'm
happy you came yeah right let me this is
our last question only because it's fun
hopefully for you can you tell me a time
in your life
when you laughed really really hard and
it doesn't have to be a great story but
if you're crying with tears
often in a situation when you're not
supposed to laugh
often somebody fell down sometimes
somebody farted
these are the prompts
[Laughter]
I'll show you a story
that would represent moments where I've
did it because I can't think of an
actual laugh like that yeah the story
that I tell is imagine you're on a big
boat going across a vast expanse of
water a lot of people on the music's
playing everyone's dancing in a moment
of carelessness you fall off the back of
the boat
and you're waving frantically and they
don't notice the music's playing
and if you realize you can't tread water
very long but you can float for a long
time
so your strategy is as you'll float to
hopefully the realize you're going to
come back looking for you now in order
to flow you have to relax or you'll sink
so how would you be relaxing out there
you'd be relaxing very uh seriously
and let's say let's say the weights are
real big like this going like this and
all day goes and it turns into night all
night long you're looking up at the
stars kind of like the next morning you
see the sun coming up and suddenly it
Dawns on you there's some very intimate
level it doesn't matter whether they
come back where you draw and it's the
same thing
and you just burp you burst out laughing
and just as you're laughing you look at
all the corner of your eye you see the
boat coming back to get you and when
they pull you on board you're so
grateful and night night in bed
a line there in the dark you're so
grateful they found you but you know
your life was really saved when you were
out there in the water and you realize
the Oneness of birth and death
you know and I think that's the last
that's the laughter well I'm gonna carve
you a trophy out of bronze and gold
plated though because that is the
greatest answer to that question of all
time it's true yeah there is a uh we
don't I'm not even gonna offer my
thoughts because that that's just a
great way to end okay would you say this
is silly uh but Richard did it mirabai
did it so we had the guests say keep it
crispy it's how we say goodbye you say
keep it crispy and then the show is over
yeah so keep it crispy
crispy extra crispy thank you so much
what a gift yeah
[Music]
thank you